[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FAUST: Hi, and
welcome to Episode 201
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Jon Foust, and I'm here
with my teammate, Brian Dorsey.
Hey, Brian.
How's it going?
BRIAN DORSEY: Good.
Hello, hello everyone.
Looking forward to a good show.
JON FAUST: This
episode, we're actually
joined by Maria Laura
Scuri from FACEIT.
She's a director of
business intelligence,
and they're doing a lot of work
in reducing toxicity in texts
and voice chat for games.
And you know I love games,
Brian, so it's definitely
going to be very interesting.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's
awesome, and I'm really
looking forward to it.
That's an incredibly
important area,
to make things better online.
JON FAUST: I'm very excited
to actually have Maria
because it's not very often
that we have many women who
are in the gaming room.
I'm particularly excited to
have Maria on this episode.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Looking forward to it.
JON FAUST: Also
we're going to get
into our question of the week.
Bryan is going to
dive in on this.
It's-- when I SSH into my
VM via different methods--
Cloud Console, GCloud,
any other method
that you would like to use--
I get a different
user name each time.
What can I do to
make that static?
BRIAN DORSEY: Oo.
SSH and Google Cloud and VMs.
I'm excited.
JON FAUST: But before that,
let's get into our cool things
of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN DORSEY: We've
got two weeks' worth,
so it was a hard
thing to choose.
There's lots of extras,
a few highlights.
One thing that
jumped out at me is
we've got a new
series of trainings
specifically for
business people who
want to kind of go deep on the
business ends of Google Cloud.
So most of our
trainings have been
for hands-on technical folks,
and this is geared more
towards making sense of
the business decisions
and how you balance
trade-offs there.
So, excited about that.
There's three of them to start--
"Business Transformation
with Google Cloud,"
"Machine Learning for Business
Professionals," and "Leading
Change in the Cloud Era."
So that'll be good to check out.
If that's you, or if there is
a kind of a business-y person
on your team who
you'd like to help
get a little more
bootstrapped to Google Cloud,
send them this way.
JON FAUST: So one of my
cool things of the week
is the addition of Microsoft
SQL Server to our Cloud SQL
portfolio.
And this is great
because there are
a lot of benefits that come
along with it, and especially
with a lot of our users, who
are more accustomed to using
Microsoft SQL Server.
If you're used to
it, the great thing
is that we're offering
multiple editions
with the current version of
SQL Server, which is great.
And you can also
use popular clients
to manage that, such as SQL
Server Management Studio.
And the other key benefits
include flexible backups,
scalability, and
high-end availability.
It should be great, so there's
a lot of [INAUDIBLE] fall
over, scaling whenever
you reach your limit,
and daily automatic backups--
or you can run them on demand.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's awesome.
Me too.
I know the people who
use a lot of SQL Server.
It has so many features.
I use a lot of them.
So you need SQL Server and it's
great that that's available
in a nice, managed fashion now.
So, next up, kind of
continuing the data theme,
is a post recently on how
to orchestrate the data
preparation side of things,
like ETL perspective
for getting data into databases
or preparing it for machine
learning, AI back ends.
And so there's
this article, "How
to Orchestrate Cloud Dataprep
Jobs Using Cloud Composer,"
which I wanted to highlight.
And Dataprep is an
integrated version
of this tool called
Wrangler from Trifacta.
And it helps kind of both
visually interactive and run
batch jobs around the full
set of data preparation
stuff you'd want to
do, and see anomalies,
and all kinds of good stuff.
And then Cloud Composer is
managed Apache Airflow, which
is a workflow management tool--
which is a little abstract,
but I think about it
kind of like executable
flow charts, when
you draw those whiteboard
diagrams about "if this,
then do that."
So you can actually make code
that makes those decisions
and executes them, like running
subprocesses or calling APIs,
and things like that.
And this is a
really great example
of setting up a full, clean
preparation pipeline using
those tools together.
So check it out.
JON FAUST: Yeah, that actually
sounds pretty amazing.
I'm probably going to
check that out myself.
So following on the AI trend,
our AI platform, Prediction,
allows data scientists
to serve models
for online predictions in
a server-less environment.
So we're announcing a
couple of updates to that.
You can now choose from a set of
compute engines, machine types,
to run your model
and you can add
GPUs, such as the
inference-optimized,
low-latency Nvidia T4.
So it's actually a
very powerful GPU.
You can actually add that to
your actual-- run your model.
And then the other
features that we
include are custom containers
and compute engine machine
types for training.
So you can choose
any combination
of CPUs, RAM, and accelerators.
And then for our
containers, they
become very useful
because you can
work with any model
framework or dependency.
If you're interested in
that, please check it out.
BRIAN DORSEY: That sounds great.
Skimming the article,
it looks like basically
having a new back-end
on Kubernetes Engine
is what allows this.
So that's a great segue
into the GKE team--
Kubernetes Engine team-- has
added detailed usage metering
as a feature, and
that's just gone
GA, or generally available.
So, all supported
and ready to use.
And what that gives
you is monitoring down
at the pod level and
then aggregating that up
to the namespaces in
Kubernetes, or to labels
that you give on the pods so
that you can see exactly how
much usage is happening
from each of the teams that
are working on things,
or different programs,
or any other dimension
that you care about.
And the reason I'm excited about
this and wanted to highlight it
is that, at some level,
getting high utilization,
like lots of usage out of the
computers you buy or rent,
is kind of the
point of containers,
and getting that without
having the programs
conflict with each other.
You really want to push
the high utilization
to get your money's worth
out of these systems,
and this helps you see
where that's happening
and where it's not.
JON FAUST: So, that wraps
it up for our cool things
of the week.
And we're pretty excited
to get to our guest, Maria,
so let's go talk to Maria.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, and on this
episode, we're joined
by Maria Scuri from FACEIT.
So, Maria, pleasure to have you.
Would you like to tell us
who you are and what you do?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Sure, well
thanks a lot for having me
today.
It's great to be here.
So, yeah, as Jon was
saying, I work at FACEIT
and I'm the Director of
Business Intelligence, which
I think you can summarize
that into two main things.
On one side we try to do
a lot of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
on so many topics.
And then on the other
side, what we really want
is to drive the culture
inside our business,
inside our company, to
make people understand
how they can use data and
how that can be used to get
insights on your day-to-day.
So making sure that when
we release a new feature,
we can actually measure the
impact instead of saying,
oh we think that's
going to do great.
But then you can't
quantify that great,
so I guess that's what
we're trying to do here.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
And I've actually heard
quite a bit about you.
A bunch of Googlers
actually told me
about the work that you do
and the work that FACEIT does,
and we just had to have
you on the episode today.
So, can you tell us
a little bit more
about what FACEIT is doing?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: So, FACEIT
is a competitive gaming
platform, which I
guess, doesn't tell much
if you're outside of gaming.
To clarify, I
think you can think
about FACEIT kind of like
a marketplace, in a way.
So on one side, you
have gamers, players
that want to take part in
different competitions that
can range from our own
proprietary matchmaking
to a different
type of tournament.
So you've got leagues, you've
got round-robin championships,
you've got this standard
single-bracket tournament.
And then on the
other side, we have
lots of people in esports
and competitive gaming
that they're actually
spending their lives
organizing these competitions.
And it ranges from
guys at school,
at university, that want to
organize their own university
league, to professional
businesses.
There's many organizations
in the sector
that are organizing different
types of competitions.
What FACEIT does, it's just
trying to get people together.
So, on one side we have
players, and on the other side
we have organizers.
And we are just basically trying
to get them to meet each other.
So we have several systems
that on the platform
actually facilitate
players to find
the right competition that kind
of matches their own interests.
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
So you've got, like, strong
competition, online gaming,
so I imagine everything
always goes smoothly
in these environments?
[LAUGHTER]
MARIA LAURA SCURI:
No, not really.
So [INAUDIBLE] have
always been a core for us,
but also for game
publishers, as well,
because we work closely with
a lot of game publishers.
So one of the
things that we have
is a very smooth
integration with the game,
so it's very easy.
Basically, with the
click of a button,
you get to FACEIT to the game.
And things are not always
that smooth when you actually
put several people that don't
know each other that well
into the same online scenario.
I think toxicity has always
been a big issue in gaming.
It's definitely an
issue for us, as well.
I think it's
probably due to some
of the aspects
about matchmaking,
or in general, the
gaming experience.
On FACEIT, for example,
just to give you an example,
we have 800,000 concurrent
players at the same time.
You need just 10 of them to
make a match, and honestly,
the likelihood that
after this match
you're going to encounter again
exactly the same other nine
players, it's close to zero.
There are probably
social inhibitions
that you would have in
another environment,
like probably at
school, they are not
going to just go into the class
and start insulting somebody
because then you're faced
with that every day, no?
But in gaming,
while, I mean, I'm
probably spending like
30 minutes of my life
with these other
nine people, and I
think the other guy
has just done something
that is really stupid--
[LAUGHTER]
--then I'm probably
going to say that to him,
and I'm probably
actually going to say
that in not such a polite way.
And I think that's,
in the end, it's
like an issue to
online behavior,
especially anywhere
you're online.
You're also like--
with video games,
in general, but in other
situations as well.
You are yourself,
but you're also
using an avatar to go
around, and I think already
that puts some of the
social inhibitions
that you maybe have
in other context,
those are lowered down.
JON FAUST: So you've got
a whole group of people,
everyone with, kind of,
lowered social inhibitions
in a stressful environment.
Things can go poorly
pretty easily, huh?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yes,
if you get, already,
people starting with
lower inhibitions.
And then, you add, on top that--
especially on FACEIT,
the environment
is really competitive
because of different reasons.
Like on one side,
we have a pathway
to become a professional
player and to actually get
the occasion to be noticed.
So as you rank up on FACEIT,
you can end up in our FACEIT Pro
League, where, for
"Counter-Strike," for example,
lots of professional players
have actually been talent
scouted from there.
In some tournaments you might
be competing for money, as well.
So I think the two
things together,
then you could
have a bomb that's
about to explode, in that way.
There's lots of tension.
Especially if you're seeing
that the match is not really
going in your direction, there's
lots of tension that builds up.
And the way that's
expressed in some cases--
not all the times, but
quite a few cases--
can be like pretty
toxic, honestly.
JON FOUST: So I'm a very
competitive gamer, myself.
I actually had a meeting
earlier this week with Brian.
And I actually told him that
I was gaming for 20 hours
straight.
And I can tell you that
after gaming for 20 hours,
your personality will
definitely change,
although it's not
really you that people
see when they're gaming.
I can say that,
after a while, once I
was on a pretty
good winning streak,
and I was just really excited
to finally be back to my rank
that I believe I belong in--
I can tell you that you start
to judge people quite often.
So the question
I really have is,
what are you really
doing to address
the toxicity in matches?
Because there are different
forms of toxicity--
throwing games, there's
verbal, there's text.
So what are you really
doing to address that?
And how does FACEIT address it?
MARIA LAURA SCURI:
So I think we are
trying to get quite an
innovative approach, when
it comes to that.
So firstly, we started
with text chat.
And that's something
that we actually
had a case study
published by Jigsaw
of how we are using and
integrating Perspective API--
one of the Google
tools-- into our system.
But on the other hand, we do
know that there's more to it.
So text is probably
just one of the ways
that toxicity is
clearly surfacing.
But, as you were
saying, there are
just so many different behaviors
that you can annoy people with.
So if we take "Counter-Strike,"
you could be griefing.
So you maybe are just blocking
the passage to somebody.
There's voice chat, you
could kill a teammate.
So there's many
different things.
So what we are
really trying to do
is, basically, build a
comprehensive system that
is going to be able to
analyze and understand each
of these different behaviors.
So we see text chat is just
like the very first milestone
for what we are
actually building.
And one of the next steps
that we have, for example,
is we are building a UI that's
going to involve our community
to actually help us understand
what they see as toxic.
Because I think that's also
the other problem that you're
actually trying to
solve is also toxicity
is a perception of toxicity.
So you don't have a clear cut
"that was definitely toxic,"
especially when it comes
to certain behavior.
There's two things
that you always
need to evaluate-- that's
intention, on one side,
and actually if that
was perceived as toxic.
Because there's some
situations where,
for example, even if what
you're saying could be,
in some scenarios,
considered toxic,
but, maybe, if I'm in
a group of friends,
then that's qualified as banter.
So there's all these
different nuances
that are not that easy to
understand on one side.
And then on the other side,
what we're really trying to do
and what our system,
basically, looks like-- we
are getting data from
different sources.
So we take text chat, we take
voice chat, we also, basically,
have the stream, an HTTP
stream of every event that
happened in the game.
And we are recording
this set of events.
So we know, for
example, if, in a match,
somebody started a vote
to kick somebody out,
we know if there
was a [INAUDIBLE]..
We know if there
were other signals.
On the basis of all
this different sources,
the first step
that we want to do
is, basically, create
cases that our players
are going to help us label.
So the first step is,
let's make this interface.
This system that we actually are
going to release in, probably,
a month it's going to go out.
But the first step
would be, let's
get the input from
our players to help
us actually understand
what's going on
and label all this data.
And then this is going
to fit, probably,
into different models
that are going to then
be able to analyze each stream.
And then, finally, we can get
a comprehensive understanding
of what really went on.
BRIAN DORSEY: So just
measuring all of this
is a real challenge.
You described a
couple of scenarios.
So those are some of
your inputs and you
get some of the labeling.
Is it all just labeling?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Labeling
is just the first step.
So if we take the chat
toxicity as an example case,
we send almost 200 million
messages to Perspective API.
For each of those messages,
we got the score back.
Then we went in.
We actually analyzed
the discourse
we were getting, because the
score, by itself, might not
necessarily mean that--
of course, the higher the score
is close to one, the more toxic
that message should
be perceived.
But the other part that we
were interested in as well,
from our side, was to also
try to understand, OK,
what is the full
sentiment in that match?
So it's not just about
the single comment,
but it's also that toxicity
usually builds other toxicity.
So we also wanted to take the
whole chat into consideration.
So on top of that, we
actually built our own machine
learning model to, basically,
get to a final score
for that user in that match.
On the basis of that score,
then Minerva, which is,
basically, our admin AI--
so we are, basically,
just trying
to replicate what a
human moderator would do.
If we had enough
people to monitor
5,000 concurrent matches or
10,000 concurrent matches,
then you probably would.
But that doesn't
really scale that well.
So on the basis of
these final scores, then
Minerva takes a certain action.
It either warns the
player or it issues a ban.
I think it was two
sides of things--
one thing was,
firstly, implementing
a perspective in
this case, then it
was a lot of understanding
what that score actually means.
But also what that
score means relative
to our specific population.
Because especially with
a system like Perspective
that was built for
a broader scenario--
like an online
perception of chat
and how each comment can
affect the conversation--
I think it's also important to
relate that with your own use
case.
Because, probably,
moderating a gaming community
of 18 to 25 year olds is very
different than my grandma
that, today, wanted to read
an article on the "Times"
and was shocked about a
specific comment that,
honestly, in the
context of gaming,
would have been
totally accepted.
So I think there's always a
little bit of differentiation
that you need to do it and
that you need to consider.
And then I think,
on top of that,
now you've got your
machine learning model,
you've got your metrics.
So in our case it's
this metric that
tries to define, let's
say, the level of chat
toxicity of the user in there.
And then you could
have another metric
that is defining the
level of voice toxicity
the user had in the match.
And then you are going to
have a third metric that tries
to understand their behavior.
You will need to
try to understand
how these metrics are going
to coexist with each other.
In our case, what
we are trying to do
is punish the behavior
rather than the user.
So we are trying to make
a distinction about,
you are being toxic versus
you did something toxic.
And we are trying to go
in the second direction.
So we are really trying
to say you did something
toxic that you
shouldn't have done,
but that doesn't
qualify you as a person.
So in our case, in
this example, like
if you were toxic in
the chat and then,
probably, like then
killed somebody,
you would be issued
two different bans.
And those bans
and those warnings
would be targeted
to the behavior.
Because ultimately,
what we are trying to do
is also pinpoint exactly
what you did wrong,
and allow you to
understand what happened,
and, possibly, learn from it.
That's the part that we
are really interested in.
And what we really want
to try to do is, actually,
finding a way of instead
of punishing toxicity,
can we prevent toxicity?
And can we do something
that actually changes
the behavior of our
user, of our players,
and, potentially, changes
it for the better?
So for us, it was
really important.
And that's something that I
was great with Perspective.
For example, for the
text chat and the model
we are developing,
it was actually also
being able to tell the
users, this is what you said,
this is how it
escalated, and this
is why it's not acceptable.
And we really valued that
feedback that we can give.
JON FOUST: I'm kind of curious
because you've mentioned
that you're currently
using our Perspective API,
and you're using this to
build out a bunch of models.
I'm curious, aside
from Perspective API,
are you utilizing any
other GCP products
to address issues in gaming?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
A lot of them.
JON FOUST: I've always
thought about toxicity
as something that is a
real big issue in gaming.
Being interested
in it myself, how
do you deal with it
culturally, as well?
Because you can see that,
maybe, in certain cultures,
certain phrasing
and certain words
are not considered not
an insult or toxic.
Whereas, in another country, it
may be completely unacceptable.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: So in
terms of GCP products,
we are using a lot
of Google BigQuery.
It's, basically, the basis
of any machine learning
that we want to
do, because that's
where we do all our
data exploration.
So everything that
happens on the platform,
it's fed into BigQuery.
So on BigQuery, we, basically,
have all of our data warehouse.
It lives there.
Another tool that we are
using a lot is Looker.
Google Cloud, I think, acquired
it a couple of months ago.
So for example, we are using
data that a lot for data
visualization.
So we usually do the first
pre-processing inside BigQuery,
and then just plot
things in Looker.
Or we're a lot Cloud
Datalab as well,
especially because that
really simplifies a lot.
When you are tackling
an issue like toxicity,
we are tracking it
in a team of people.
So it was really
important for us
to be able to collaborate
on Jupyter Notebook as well.
If you don't use Cloud
Datalab, but you're
building your own
Notebook locally,
then you need to send
that file into an HTML,
or you need to download
that file somehow,
and then send it to
the other person that
needs to work on it, then
you need to share it.
You might be sharing
the code base in GitHub,
but sometimes that's not enough.
So for example, Datalab
was really useful for us
because it's integrated
directly with BigQuery.
So you can easily
pull SQL queries
that you would run on
BigQuery, and you can put them
inside your Notebook.
So that's super easy.
And then on the other side,
it was very good for us
because you can share them.
And, basically, you can have
multiple people working on it.
So that was great.
Then, of course, we are
using the Cloud AI platform.
So we are building our
machine learning model
and it's living there.
We are using mainly TensorFlow.
For example, one
of the things that
really helped there
is, on FACEIT, we
generate lots of data.
For example, Perspective--
we had 200 million messages
that we wanted to analyze
and process them quickly.
You can simply do that locally.
So being on Cloud AI and being
able to spawn a machine, where
you can, basically,
process as many data
as you want, depending
on the machine
you're actually spawning.
It's simplified
the process a lot.
I think it took a
lot of headaches
away that you don't really want
the data science to think of.
When it comes to
architecture, you
don't want to have DevOps
experts or data science
teams thinking about how to
set up a virtual machine.
You just want to get
that done, to get that
with a click, which is
something that you can do
on Cloud AI, which was great.
And then, actually,
before, we were
using a tool of a competitor,
but we've seen today,
on your Cloud AI,
that you actually
have a tool for data labeling.
So we have started testing that
out, which is in beta right.
So we have a data set being
labeled right now on there.
JON FOUST: I'm still
kind of curious
about those cultural
differences and how can
you consider what's
toxic and what's not.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: So I think
there are several things.
So on one side, when it
comes to Perspective API,
it actually has models
in different languages.
So right now, it supports
Spanish, French, and English.
And then there's
three models that
are in beta, which is, I
think, Italian, Portuguese,
and another one.
Then we have been
talking with them a lot
about Russian, because we have
a lot of Russian new users
and that's one thing that
we need to factor in.
Of course, right now, we are
doing some approximation.
Because one of the
things, for example,
we have to do to
score a message,
was to, firstly, send
it to Translate API--
so that's another Google
tool that we are using--
get the translation back, and
then we score the translation.
One thing that we did
to try to minimize
the errors and
cultural difference
was, when we had the
data set labeled,
we had it labeled by people
that were from that culture.
So we were splitting the data.
So we were asking,
basically, Russian people
to review Russian
messages, Italian people
to review Italian messages,
and so on, to actually get
an understanding
of the differences.
Right now, what we are
really trying to do,
which, I think,
kind of minimized
the problem in our use
case, we are really
trying to go after behavior
that are really, really toxic.
So when we released
this first model
into our production
system and then it
started automatically
warning and banning people--
to give you an idea,
we are, basically,
targeting the top 5%
of most toxic behavior.
So within that range, yes,
cultural differences are still
there, but not as much.
Because, on the
opposite side, I do
think that a slight
bit of toxicity
is part of competitiveness.
It's like thinking that
football players would lightly
insult themselves on the field.
It's just feels like
it can get to a point
where you're just, basically,
being the Big Brother,
watching on everything,
and censoring everything.
You still kind of need
to keep a balance.
And you need,
also, to understand
you can't go after
everything, because then it
would kind of put yourself at
the opposite end, I would say.
BRIAN DORSEY: You used
the word banter earlier.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
Exactly.
BRIAN DORSEY: In a competition,
you've got this going on.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
So I think there is
some banter going on.
And I think you don't
want I get into a position
that your model is, actually,
like banning for banter.
So you still want to
find that middle area.
Then there were things that
were a bit tricky, for example,
with using Perspective.
Or, in general, if the gaming
language has a lot of slang.
So that was one of
the tricky bits--
to factor that slang
into our model.
So there were some efforts
on that side that we put in.
And then on the other side
are things that are not
acceptable in other contexts.
There are actually standard
terms in a game like
"Counter-Strike:
Global Offensive."
For example, if I say, nice
head shot in "Counter-Strike,"
it's actually meant
to be a compliment.
But outside of it, you
might be inciting violence.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Context differences.
So toxicity is a huge
challenge everywhere online.
And I think many of the
folks who are listening
are building and
running systems where
users interact with each other.
Do you have
recommendations for them
on how to apply some
of the things you've
learned in this space?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
I think it's the two things--
on one side, before
using this approach,
we were trying to
go down the approach
that I think is used by many
that's more like building
a karma my system.
So it tries to get an index
that tries to represent
how toxic of a player you are.
I think, in general, a
karma system works good
when you are trying to build
that as an honor score,
like more of how good
of a player you are,
rather than how bad
of a player you are.
Or, in general, not just
in gaming, but everywhere.
I think, on one side, it's
trying to enforce the positive.
Then, on the other side, I
also think, know your context.
So know what you're
dealing with.
Because I think toxicity can
be so many different things.
I mean, even on, let's
say, a social network,
I can be toxic by writing
a very, very bad comment,
or I can be toxic by
posting a bad image,
or I could post a video
that is out of spite.
And those are all like
different data signals.
When I say, know your
context, it's also,
know how toxicity
can express itself.
And consider all these
different sources.
And the fact is that you kind
of need to deal with all of them
because, otherwise,
people are smart.
So if they find out you
cannot write a swear word
in your comment, they're
probably going to put a swear
word in your image, if
they notice that detecting
the image.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
They'll figure
something else out.
MARIA LAURA SCURI:
So they're going
to think of something else.
So you need to know them.
And you need to try to use
as comprehensive an approach
as you can.
And then I think the
other side is also
to celebrate the small wins.
It's a huge issue.
And I think he needs to be
broken down into smaller ones.
And then you need to tackle each
smaller issue, one at a time.
Because, otherwise,
if you're trying
to just tackle
everything and then
go out with this super big
system that tries to solve it
all, you might not get the
result. Instead, I'm thinking,
step by step.
So just release the
first small thing.
See, also, which affects it has.
Because one thing
is, we are people.
So we learn from things.
So that's also one of the
things that you want to rely on.
When you start
pushing for change,
then, hopefully, people are
going to follow as well.
So they are actually going to
help you in what you are doing.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So you, basically, said
think about behavior
instead of reputation overall.
So what people are
doing in the moment.
And that helps with these
short term things as well.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
Because I also think that
it helps you in many ways.
It helps into accepting
criticism better.
So I think like that's
always something
I have been thinking of.
And that's why that
was one of the things
that I really pushed
and FACEIT embraced.
And I think we are, basically,
trying to build this.
And then, hopefully,
maybe in the future,
this can become a tool
that other game publishers.
But it's also really
swapping from criticize you
as a person, which is usually
not taken that well-- and also,
who am I to criticize
you as a person?
Maybe you are just
having a bad day.
So I just want to point out
that you did something wrong.
And I think that's
taken a lot better, also
in a personal point
of view, in general.
School or such is
very different,
when you tell a kid
you did something wrong
or, instead, you tell them,
well, you're being a bad kid.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
It's really interesting to hear
about aligning the software
systems to what's
actually just, basically,
good, interpersonal,
human behavior.
It's kind of a
classic recommendation
to talk about the behavior
rather than the person.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
Exactly.
I think what we're trying
to do is, actually--
I think artificial intelligence
and machine learning
are as smart as people are.
Or they can be as
smart as people are.
And it's not that artificial
intelligence is just
this magical thing.
It depends on how you build it.
So what we are really trying
to build with Minerva as well
is we can make her think
the way we think, in a way.
So it's more like if
there are practices
that are good in
human relations,
why should we forget
about them when
we are in a technological field
and we are trying to build.
BRIAN DORSEY: Love it.
Love it, love it, love it.
So if people are
motivated and want
to learn more about
this space, do you
have recommendations
for where to go next?
JON FOUST: Besides becoming
a super competitive gamer.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yes.
Play a lot.
No.
There's the case study
that was published today
on the Jigsaw blog post.
BRIAN DORSEY: We'll put a
link to that in the notes.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
Perspective API-- there's lots
of good documentation there.
If you read about
toxicity in gaming,
there's lots of articles
coming up about it.
Actually, lots of studies from
researchers in academia about,
in general, how to apply machine
learning and AI on toxicity.
But as a general
model, and then you
can always take that
learning and see
how they fit in your own space.
BRIAN DORSEY: Can
we ask you for one
to three
recommendations we could
put in the show notes for
specific papers to look at?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
Sure.
I can send those over.
JON FOUST: Is there
anything that we've
missed that you would like to
mention before we wrap things
up?
Or would you like
to let listeners
know where we can find you?
Or we can find any material
that you're posting,
so that we can stay up
to date with everything
that FACEIT is doing?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
I'm going to be at
Google Next in London.
So if anybody's there, I'm happy
to have a chat with anybody.
And I'm probably going
to be at GDC as well.
So FACEIT-- you can
find us on Medium.
So blog.faceit.com.
That's a good way to keep up to
speed with what we are doing.
I'm quite talkative, so there
are some blogs about what
we are doing around
toxicity, and what
we want to do, and so on.
And then faceit.com.
If you're a gamer and
actually fancy a match,
we'd be happy to see you there.
JON FOUST: And I know
that you're a gamer.
I've never publicly
shared my gamer handle
or what games I play,
but if you would
like your listeners to
probably hop on the sticks
and play with you--
I don't know if you want
to share your gamer handles
or anything?
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
So I'm FACEITLulu.
You can find me on "League of
Legends," "World of Warcraft."
That's two main games, but,
usually, you can find me
around plenty of games.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
And I guess I'll
follow the same suit.
And you can find me mostly on
"Overwatch" and in [INAUDIBLE]..
So I'll definitely link my
battle tags on that as well.
BRIAN DORSEY: New information.
Awesome.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Yeah.
That's really awesome.
See?
New things that we learned
about John as well.
BRIAN DORSEY: You can
only find out here.
Thank you so much for spending
time with us and sharing.
It really feels like you're
pushing things forward
to make things better for
humans interacting online.
So thank you so much.
MARIA LAURA SCURI: Thank
you so much for having me.
It was a pleasure.
JON FOUST: So we would like
to thank our guest, Maria,
for joining us on this episode.
It was really amazing to hear
about all the cool things that
FACEIT it is doing to, pretty
much, end toxicity in gaming
or put a dent in it.
I play competitive
games quite often.
And toxicity is one of the major
things I've contributed myself,
I'll be honest.
But it's really great
to see someone's really
trying to make a change
in the gaming space.
BRIAN DORSEY: I totally agree.
And I'm, personally, really
looking forward to seeing--
I mean, gaming is a particularly
tough space for this.
I'm looking forward to seeing
the tools and techniques that
come out of there, hopefully,
branch into other areas.
Because we have challenging
environments in, pretty much,
all of our online
social networks.
So I'm looking forward to
seeing improvements there.
JON FOUST: Games are meant
to bring people together.
Maybe FACEIT's platform will
help bring people closer
together by ending toxicity.
So Brian, our
question of the week
is going to be directed
straight at you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: That
question of the week
was, when I SSH in my VM
via different methods,
I get a different username.
So what can I do to
make that static?
BRIAN DORSEY: That can
be super confusing.
Because if you're, by default--
and this is talking about
SSH-ing into Compute Engine
instances-- the user
name is kind of just
passed through from what
your host environment is.
So if you're on
the Cloud console,
that's going to be the first
part of your email address
of whatever you're log
in to Google Cloud is.
Then, if you, later, go and
SSH in from your laptop,
you might have a different
user name on your laptop.
And then you're logging
into the same machine,
but you end up with
two different user
accounts on that end.
And your dot files
don't work the same way,
or the permissions
and it gets all confusing.
So there's a couple of options.
One is that you could
change all of things.
Now that's not so super useful.
When you SSH in
from your laptop--
and this is a feature that
might not be that known,
so just to talk about it a bit.
As part of gcloud, there's a
gcloud compute ssh, and then
an instance name.
And since you're already logged
in with OAuth to Google Cloud,
it handles the SSH key pair
exchange and all that sort
of stuff for you.
And it just does all
the configurations,
so you don't have
to worry about it.
But one of the things it
does in that automatic thing
is figure out what user to use.
And it just infers
that from your laptop.
So the fix is, actually, really
simple but hard to notice.
So it's great if you know
it's there, not if you don't.
And it's, basically,
you just add,
instead of just the instance
name, user@ the instance name.
And then that will set the
remote user to log into.
And you're good to go.
So gcloud compute
SSH, user@ instance.
And that will work.
So that's the short version.
There is a more, kind of
managed version of SSH keys
that work at the
organization level.
That's called OS log in.
And if you're using
that, when you submit
your SSH key, your public
key, to use the first time,
you can also specify
the user name
that should be used on
the instances there.
And, of course, you're
logging into, usually,
a Linux box, in
this case, for SSH.
So you can use UNIX commands.
And you can always pseudo
su into the user you
want on the other end as well.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Wow.
That's a handful.
Glad that you can tackle all
of those different methods.
BRIAN DORSEY: That was
kind of a lot of words.
We'll put a couple links in
the show notes to the docs
with some examples.
JON FOUST: So thanks,
Brian, for tackling
all of those different
methods of actually
SSH-ing into your
actual GCE instance.
Glad that you can
offer our listeners
multiple methods and the
nuances to using each one.
So Brian, I'm curious,
where are you going to be?
What are you doing in
the upcoming months?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So I've recently switched to
being all in on Compute Engine
and use cases around that.
So as part of that, I'm kind
of doing a bunch of learning
and heads down time.
So that's where the
majority of my time is.
But I'm also going
to be at a conference
called Supercomputing.
That's in Denver, in November.
Interesting conference.
It's a mix of academia
and industry stuff.
So I'm excited about that.
JON FOUST: And I will be at
a series of different places.
I'll be an Anime NYC.
That's just a
personal thing for me,
in November, right prior to
going to KubeCon, in November,
where we're running our
matchmaking and game server
workshop.
So if you're going to be
there, please, check us out.
And then I get to
hang out with our eng
team for our Open
Match [INAUDIBLE],,
in Google Kirkland in December.
And then I'll probably end up
taking a very small business
trip to Montreal to hang
out with some gaming folks.
And then I go on
vacation, finally.
So I'm really excited to wrap
up my end of the year travel
and have some fun.
BRIAN DORSEY: Sounds good.
JON FOUST: We would like to
thank you all for listening.
And Brian, it's been
a pleasure, as always.
BRIAN DORSEY: Likewise.
JON FOUST: So we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]